[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs toutes vos idées sorties
culturelles ou ludiques dans le
département merci d'un or autrefois pour
ce nouveau numéro est à quelques jours
de la veille de la toussaint ce vendredi
27 octobre sera un spécial halloween
venez trembler d'effroi à voisins le
bretonneux une soirée pour fêter
halloween est organisée samedi 28
octobre des jeux de société des films
terrifiant un événement mis en place par
l'association sous jobs sa présidence
que nous donnera le programme et que
serait cette fête sans ses déguisements
effrayants plus que quelques jours pour
choisir le vôtre à magny les hameaux
certains vont créer eux mêmes nous
allons récolter quelques conseils
enfermés là ni poker nous donnera des
idées pour compléter sa tenue un sacs à
bonbons personnalisés
une petite chauve-souris indispensable
pour ranger ses friandises du roi gagner
aux fermes de gally venez sculpter votre
citrouille au jack o lantern c'est la
fête de la citrouille jusqu'au 31
octobre
les ateliers sont proposés aux enfants
de 3 à 12 ans un spectacle est également
prévue l'après-midi un rendez vous
immanquable pour bien préparer sa
décoration à l'éffigie de jack o'lantern
personnages incontournables d'alwyn
aurélie rond et marie anne et rats ont
suivi l'une de ces animations on écoute
un mot
les enfants viennent avec leur
citrouille
le chapeau il l'a vide à l'intérieur et
et redessine ce qu'ils veulent pour
faire les yeux le nez la bouche et non
leur des coûts en fonction de ce qu'ils
veulent on essaye de faire sodeci trucs
qui font peur sur des citrouilles qui
font pas peur par mois vraiment ce que
veulent les enfants et repartent avec
essais des citrouilles qu'on fait
pousser directement à la ferme de gally
[Musique]
est justement un exemple de ces
citrouilles donc vous pouvez le voir
donc de la ferme de gally réalisé avec
l'aide de nos deux journalistes
les monstres sorcières et autres
fantômes sont bientôt de sortie à
voisins le bretonneux ils ont même une
soirée dédiée samedi 28 octobre
quelques jours avant halloween la
terreur s'invite ce déjà à l'espace
culturel decauville audrey bordas
présidente de l'association soudja en
charge de l'organisation de cette soirée
est avec nous bonjour bonjour alors pour
cette soirée appelée n'aime pas peur
vous avez prévu du cinéma des jeux de
société et bien sûr de la restauration
ça commence à 17 heures l on va d'abord
parler des deux premiers films qui sont
destinés à un public plutôt jeune est-ce
que vous pouvez nous mais présentait
alors oui effectivement ces deux films
plutôt au public famille alors le
premier don frankenweenie qui est un
petit frankenstein deux enfants ou un
enfant perd son animal de compagnie qui
est passionné de sciences en plus et qui
va trouver maintes et maintes raisons et
maintes et maintes choses pour pouvoir
justement le faire revenir à la vie
donc c'est un aîné un film d'animation
en marionnettes créé par tim burton
il est très intéressant à voir et
et qui peut apporter aussi beaucoup de
choses aux enfants notamment du côté de
la science et du côté de ba de
l'affronter dit un petit peu qu'il est
vraiment très sympa et je le conseille
vraiment famille un deuxième film c'est
bienvenue à zombieland
alors bienvenue à zombieland en plus
celui là il peut inter il peut
intervenir avec la partie vraiment ado
parce qu'il est vraiment marrant c'est
entre guillemets c'est comment survivre
à une attaque de zombies et avait que 13
14 raison de ce qu'il faut faire ce
qu'il faut pas faire et notamment long
que les gros codes du film d'horreur qui
sont vraiment dinin dans juste avant
l'heure vous avez évoqué évoqué
frankenweenie sortie est justement le
jour d'halloween en 2012 et je vous
propose de regarder un extrait de la
bande annonce
même après la mort les muscles
réagissent-elles et les flics
[Musique]
j'ai arrangé ça va voilà un petit garçon
qui veut recréer son chien là qu'il a
qu'il a perdu et pour les plus grands à
partir de 12 ans il y aura deux congés
ring donc adapté d'une histoire vraie
celle d'un couple d'enquêteurs
paranormaux qui devront affronter une
présence démoniaque iac sortie en 2013
alors ça c'est le film qui termine la
soirée
et juste avant pour les plus grands
aussi il ya un classique du cinéma
massacre à la tronçonneuse alors
massacre à la tronçonneuse c'est un des
plus grands classiques du cinéma ce
qu'on appelle donc le slasher movie qui
est donc le plus improbable qui soit le
monsieur sort de là d'une feinte dotant
d'un endroit direct avec une
tronçonneuse
on l'entendra jamais à 3 km arrivée mais
voilà sinon c'est beaucoup trop
mais c'est le principe du slasher movie
c'est ce qui fait les soirées typique
halloween et c'est pour ça qu'on passe
ce type de ce film là et puis la version
86 est une version qui est assez
intéressant à voir même pour les plus
fans entre guillemets de montage ou de
ou de vision cinématographique il est
vraiment assez sympa à voir donc autant
de spectateurs que connaisseurs c'est
vrai que c'est un bon micmac s'adresse à
tous et là encore justement je vous
propose un extrait de la bande annonce
par ailleurs on se retrouve juste après
j'adore cette loi se mêlent
[Musique]
inouï coeur de ce paysage h
il est non
mottaki
[Musique]
on le rappelle tout de même que ce film
est interdit aux moins de 16 ans donc
pour ceux qui ne pourraient ou ne
voudrait en tout simplement pas assister
à ces deux dernières séances
des jeux de société sont également
proposées toute la soirée c'est ça en
fait on sort des jeux de société sur le
thème halloween donc comme un zombie
side où le but du jeu c'est de s'en
sortir en coopération
donc c'est un jeu de plateau un jeu de
zombies et le but donc c'est d'arriver à
être ensemble à penser aux bonnes
combinaisons vous pouvoir échapper des
zombies et et gagner donc la partie
après il y aura pour les plus jeunes y
aura bazar bizarre
il y aura aussi le labyrinthe enfin il
ya énormément de jeux qui seront
proposés mais tous dans le thème
halloween dont le l'éternel de garou
quand même qu'ils partagent
incontournable également
il y aura aussi un coin restauration un
mot également sur les modalités comment
est-ce qu'on peut rejoindre cette soirée
alors pas déjà sur la soirée est
entièrement gratuite donc tous les films
sont gratuits n'hésitez pas à venir dans
la limite bien sûr des places
disponibles puisque c'est dans une salle
est le seul point qui est payant c'est
donc la buvette et la restauration
il y aura des crêpes des pop corn et des
brochettes de bonbons pour vous proposer
sur place on donnera un petit sachet de
bonbons pour les enfants quand même à la
à l'entrée puisque c'était le but de
notre première manifestation
et voilà et sinon après il y aura donc
de la bière je fais n'a pu puisque ces
vols seles une bière locale vers une
super bonne
mais à consommer avec modération bien
sûr et plus tôt pour la modération pour
les adultes toutes les façons nous
demanderons les cartes d'identité à
l'entrée et au bar de toutes les façons
pour pas voir de problème et il y aura
du soda et des jus de fruits pour les
enfants et un derniers mois c'est rapide
alors à ce que vous nous présenter votre
association ça fait longtemps vous
organiser cette soirée
alors on a organisé cette soirée alors
cette soirée là non c'est la première
année sous ce format là on l'a
organisait deux ans de suite sous le
format souhaité fait moins peur donc une
manifestation qui est aussi au parc de
covile en extérieur on loue un chapiteau
on avait un ennemi 200 personnes sur
place c'était une manifestation à ces
grosses où on avait des partenariats
avec beaucoup d'associations locales
avec aussi
on avait des spectacles déjà sur place
des cinémas des pour des films qui
étaient projetés on avait des jeux pour
les enfants
mais cette forme à là on n'a pas pu le
ce format là n'avaient pu faire à cause
du plan vigipirate et d'état d'urgence
qu'on me tende aura toujours moyen de
s'amuser quand on voit son nom mais là
vous venez de vous venez ce week-end
vous allez vous amuser c'est sûr on vous
a préparé quelque chose qui est assez
énorme en termes de déco pas parfait bon
malade de voir ça en tout cas merci
beaucoup d'heureux bordas vous avoir
présenté votre soirée spéciale halloween
donc soirée gratuite on le rappelle à
destination des petits comme des plus
grands mais l'entrée est libre mais
n'oubliez pas l'inscription obligatoire
les coordonnées s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci beaucoup audrey bordas
aida merci à vous et bien sûr qui dit
halloween dit costumes les petits
monstres s'activent pour devenir les
plus effrayants possible à magny les
hameaux des ateliers sont proposés pour
réaliser son propre déguisements les
arrêts jambes a profité pour recueillir
quelques idées
une
à vos feutre ciseaux confectionner les
petits et les grands ont pu réaliser des
masques et des costumes pour le jour
d'halloween en compagnie de leurs
parents les enfants se sont imaginés en
vampires sorcières et autres dj soirée
il
[Musique]
gd de repérer du faux seins et j'ai une
robe de sorcier sur deux après midi les
ateliers ou accueilli 30 cents
participants enfants et parents on
accepte toute la famille avec tous les
membres des enfants toutes les tranches
d'âge et parce que ici un organisme pour
chaque enfant quelque chose donc il ya
le coloriage
il ya les ateliers création des masques
pour les plus grands il ya les costumes
pour les mamans et les grands enfants
donc je pense c'est ça qui facilite le
devenir de la participation des familles
une fois les caps et les robes essayé
puis ajuster les petits gourmands sont
impatients d'être le jour j parce que on
peut sortir dehors pour aller demander
des bonbons
on peut aller chercher des bonbons on ne
fait pas aux gens les enfants pourront
arborer leurs déguisements mardi 31
octobre lors du défilé d'halloween à
l'estaminet
[Musique]
une fois le déguisement fait vous allez
sûrement partir pour la chasse aux
bonbons
il ne vous manque qu'un objet
indispensable pour frapper pour les
frapper à la porte des voisins le sac à
friandises
mélanie vous savez comment fabriquer un
an fabrique un même en une quinzaine de
minutes deux minutes à peu près leur
pour mon sac moi j'ai choisi de faire
une chauve souris
j'en ai même fait d'horizon pas tout à
fait la même elle peut-être mais vous
pouvez aussi faire une citrouille une
araignée pourquoi pas un fantôme la base
de toute manière est toujours la même
vous changerez juste les couleurs du
papier les décorations
donc il nous faut une paire de ciseaux
de la colle un crayon et une agrafeuse
est une forme ronde pour créer le sac
parce qu'en fonction de la taille du sac
vous pouvez prendre un bol un vase un
plat moi j'ai choisi carrément un
couvercle de boîte à gâteaux et j'ai
aussi choisi de travailler que du papier
à dessin
mais pourquoi pas utilisé du tissu alors
pour commencer j'ai coupé en deux un
feuille on l'a vu tout à l'heure j'ai
aussi fait le couvercle avec le
couvercle de la boîte à gâteaux j'ai
dessiné le contour du sac ne fait pas le
rond complet parce que la partie plate
vous permettra de faire l'ouverture et
vous découpez les deux femmes on vient
de le voir aussi à l'écran vérifiez bien
par contre quel son égal parce que après
ça vous permettre de former le sac qui
sans oublier de créer le lent ce qui me
permettra de le porter ou est lancée
elle doit se mettre en même temps que
les deux les deux parties mais il suffit
juste là aussi de découper une bande de
papier ou de tissus moi j'ai choisi du
blanc pour changer les vous pouvez
rester dans le tournoi re pour que tous
tiennent plusieurs possibilités une
colle qui tient très bien des agrafes
comme sur les images mais vous pouvez
aussi coudre ça demande un peu plus de
temps et de patience mais c'est tout à
fait réalisable sur le papier à dessin
moi je les fais sur un des deux modèles
et on termine par le plus amusant
forcément la déco et bien sûr pour faire
une belle chose sourit il faut lui faire
des yeux une jolie bouche ne voulait
surtout pas les dents ou là aussi j'ai
décidé de tout faire avec du papier
blanc les une tête les petites notes de
couleurs c'est avec des feutres un petit
coup de colle une fois de plus et la
finition les ailes on les voit il faut
les découper sur des chutes de papier ça
fait quelques arbres ou des là aussi au
l'école à l'arrière du sac et voilà moi
je suis prête pour aller sonner aux
portes de mes voisins et ne pas oublier
surtout la fameuse phrase en dit
en sable un bonbons ou un sort merci
mélanie pour cette idée de sacs à
bonbons pour compléter notre déguisement
on prend maintenant on passe maintenant
notre agenda avec deux derniers rendez
vous à noter
[Musique]
venez courir pour le 1er novembre aux
clayes-sous-bois une course à pied
déguisée au coeur de la forêt deux
trails dès 9h10 8 ou 10 km également la
possibilité de s'inscrire sur le
parcours de marche nordique de 10 km lui
aussi les participants sont invités à
venir déguisés et une soupe à la
citrouille est proposé à l'arrivée le
soir pour les amateurs de frissons et de
cluedo géant une murder party est
organisée au pavé du canal à montigny le
bretonneux
la légende raconte que le lendemain
d'halloween des personnages des livres
prennent vie dans les librairies dès
19h30 il faudra résoudre une enquête en
compagnie de l'auteur de romans
policiers paul smith 7 accessible aux
enfants dès 10 ans le 7-8 loisirs est
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivis nous espérons que vous avez fait
le plein d'idées sorties pour halloween
pour préparer halloween
n'oubliez pas ce week-end nous changeons
d'heure il faudra reculer sa montre
d'une heure dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche
je vous retrouve vendredi prochain pour
un nouveau numéro et je vous souhaite de
très belles vacances
oui
[Musique]
ouais
oh
m